guys you asked for it for so long we
finally got it merch is on sale right
now uh we really talk about it but i
want to start pushing it because we have
a really cool designs that joe and i
made up ourselves and it's the limited
run so whatever is on sale now the
second it's sold out it's not coming
back it's available right now uh in the
links on these videos or at our website
savilcanocomedy.comderosainfo.com
that's taste buds merch i also have solo
merch uh up there as well uh and so
check all of it out and uh
and and buy some merch tweeted us the
merch and we will retweet you or repost
you on instagram we want to see which
ones you guys are liking and we want to
see the merch out in the wild really
cool project that we put together so to
see it out there
is going to be cool so check out
our merch for perch
jonarosainfo.com for your uh show
information ticket links all that stuff
coming up next october we got dead crow
comedy club in north carolina
in november i'll be going to michigan do
a bunch of shows and i've got tons of
other stuff around that stuff and after
that stuff and coming up in the new year
and all that anyway you can find all of
it at
jodarossainfo.com also if you're in new
york city please come to my bar in
sandwich shop joey roses uh all info for
there is joeyrosesnyc.com
we're open
six days a week
opening at 12 p.m every day great
sandwiches awesome hang
and lots of booze
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds on today's episode
of taste buds
uh i
i admit i admit in my past on this show
i have argued a lot of dumb stuff
that was the the surefire loser
but today
salvolcano
steps in
to the target zone
in defending
pepsi that's right in the battle of coke
versus pepsi what are you talking about
is pepsi you got the right one baby
right where ray charles ray charles no
that's california raisins though isn't
it no you got the right one baby that
was ray charles and they did it in the
movie he punched his wife and then he
had a pepsi
and also didn't michael jackson was that
pepsi pepsi michael jackson was pepsi
and he burnt his hair right yeah but you
got the right one maybe is that pepsi or
coke
it might be can we look that up pimpy
so look here's the thing does he hit his
wife in the movie
i don't remember i don't want to i don't
want to slander uh
ray charles who knows i don't know i
have his book up today did every biopic
somebody hit somebody
it's always terrible it should be hey
the everyone should be called hey you
know how you thought you liked this guy
yeah because that's the only reason to
make a biopic
everything's everything's everything's
great by the way i watched elvis
i don't know how you cried through it
man i thought it was just like racist
hold on ready
racism that was it racist i watched
elvis as well
pimp it was a white guy walking around
going that black lady has a good bar i'm
gonna take that and make a song oh
that's not what it was pimp shut up your
generation bothers me
i don't think it was racist but but i
mean you know
elvis has the criticism of taking you
know pop popularizing rock and roll
taking it from black culture yes but in
the movie he gives and i hope it's true
to life he gives credit constantly
throughout the intensive i saw the movie
i watched it uh it was very it was very
uh uh
stylized i wasn't expecting to be that
stylized director of moulin rouge yeah
bass yeah so i will say i thought it was
interesting
i i didn't think it was the tour de
force that a lot of people are telling
me it was and i
i did it when did you cry
well i could imagine that uh it might
not have been the same experience that i
had in the theater as you watched it
half distracted from your couch
but yeah you know i mean part of it but
no but you said you were moved to tears
what part i don't uh
[Applause]
well
i cried multiple times in the movie okay
the ending in particular
but then also when he uh i don't i don't
think i i think i fell asleep before the
end
jesus christ i turned it off
the i mean i watched it this is
this is this is just
plus hours this is the world we live in
like three hours yeah i i watch like i
watch
i watched like 80 of it and i was like
that's good it's like a lot more of the
same going on here so tom hanks was
cringy in it didn't you so people are
saying he's amazing and he's cringy i
didn't i thought it sounded hokey
his i thought his voice in a hokey and i
thought of the process
and i thought
and i thought the prosthetics look hokey
oh [ __ ] i i feel like you look how you
get a rise out of me shut up no i s why
i'm shooting you straight
you thought his voice sounded hokey yes
i thought he was like well i told you
what i could do it in the spot oh tom
[Music]
oh no and the prosthetics on tommy cause
i don't look a little weird that [ __ ] i
will say this about thomas
he i mean no shake to the top
yeah he was incredible
he
the accent he speaks in the very little
footage you can find of colonel tom
parker on youtube yeah
but there is footage like you can listen
to his voice he does not talk like that
so i was a little confused straw's
killing me can you take the straw out of
that thing no okay thank you it's my
drink i'm not taking the straw out
because you're a psycho
[Music]
it distracts me from being my at my top
of my game oh is that what it is that's
what it is
i keep looking
[Music]
i
ate
one-fourth of the quesadilla this guy
literally once
one-fourth of a quesadilla doesn't sound
funny does it
does
yeah but just lies is what you do you
just do lies
oh wow he does look like him i did all
the promotion
the outdoor advertising
and he did the show on the stage
and the fans made it possible
you could promote all you want to that
doesn't sound like tom hanks at all
it's like a normal guy
he literally sounds like just a guy
tom hanks was doing an almost like
like almost like a [ __ ] keeper voice or
something and throughout something
tom actually was doing soda voice from
his joke about you think this bad
neighborhood yes yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah he was doing some sort of like uh
batman villain i got to tell you that's
some look he's rocking
i've only he looks he he does like the
prosthetics i was like he does have this
no he does kind of look like he looks
like a white fred berry right
rewrote yeah it's funny you bring that
up i started watching uh on toby
i love to be toby's so good of course
you do
that's what makes so much to watch
the app isn't it gone isn't it gone no
no toby's an app oh i thought it was
okay yeah no you're thinking of queebie
you're thinking of quibby quibby no 2b
is a streaming app that's like a netflix
or something and it's completely but why
don't you just oh it's free it's
completely free because that's
commercials okay and there's no option
to not have commercials there's just
stuff they're like this is free and
there's commercials and that's what it
is it has so much awesome content really
so much i've been looking for i've been
looking for truly um old 80s sitcoms
i want to watch like i want to watch
like punky brewster silver spoons that's
what's on tubey what and i've been
rocking it
what's happening what's happening and
full what's happening now yes
yes and i watched i watched a crowd huh
three is a crowd
i don't know but i wouldn't be surprised
wait these are these are just free
movies yeah two pieces that can't be
real
these movies are just free to watch
because they have commercials that's
what i'm saying so i go to 2b.com i
watch
i literally go to tv download the app
and that's it i go to 2b.com and i watch
what part of you want to understand
right now he can click right now we will
start watching holy [ __ ] lean on me
you're that's crazy it's not it has
commercials that's how it's crazy though
it's still on demand television for free
well
yeah i guess how how many commercials oh
my goodness very limited to be honest i
had i had i had hulu with commercials
for a minute yeah because it was like
part of a package deal she had the
commercial one it is it's a who's a lot
of commercials yeah this is like it's
barely any like i i've i've gone through
episodes of things where i don't think
there was a commercial break all right
well you know what they should be paying
us money for this
well no they shouldn't because they're
giving it away for free it's a free but
we're promoting it they're getting ads
who cares we're doing a tribute winter
hours we're trying to get alpha on the
show uh
it's nice isn't it i've never been on
the show they're gonna have a puppet on
[Laughter]
i mean look i love you to pieces
you know out
that's true i'm not gonna bring in the
numbers
it's very true look at this there's a
menudo tv show
what
or i guess that's a documentary i would
assume
that's ricky martin i think ricky martin
was in menudo
we talked about this but you know menudo
is not one one group right
menudo is just they cycle them out
as soon as the guy the hispanic guy gets
too old they bring a young hispanic guy
it's it's an evolving thing yeah but but
i thought
am i wrong i thought minuto went farther
than that i thought it was actually much
more a much even more sinister thing
i thought that minuto was several groups
of guys
called minuto
i don't know and they just like they're
like here's minuto for chili here's
minuto for no over here
i could i could be a thousand percent
wrong on that but
what does menudo even mean it's just a
mexican cuisine menudo also known as
pancetta panchita
or stomach sauce it's a very mexican
sausage
are you kidding me that the name of this
puerto rican boy band
it's amazing named after a mexican soup
that's also known as stomach sauce
menudo's
oh wait menu is puerto rican i thought
they were mexican
no because it's named after the mexican
cuisine
menudo is a puerto rican boy band which
formed in puerto rico by producer
edgardo diaz referred to as the most
iconic latino i'll stop i'll stop
talking
[Music]
i was gonna i was gonna enhance the
thing before you get too far i'm joking
there's no way to say puerto rican boy
bad word doesn't quite racist
that's a way
puerto rican is a hardest puerto rican
boyfriend
sounds great and you're not even being
racist
all right i'm sorry go ahead well let's
go back up to the
uh the most iconic latino pop music band
menudo has been ranked as one of the
biggest boy bands of all time uh school
pimp the band had several radio hits the
accident television film in 1979
which is i think what we were just
looking noodle's original lineup
consisted of five boys two sets of
brothers fernando and nefti salaberry
ages 12 and 13. the melendez brothers
carlos and oscar who i think killed
their parents later 12 and 11. that's
the menendez and then ricky melendez age
nine
i think they were that young oh wait is
ricky martin ricky melendez that's
the band's golden era lineup consisted
of
i don't know click on ricky melendez
no no it's different
yeah because ricky martin was the one
that as a as the group entered the 1990s
and their popularity started to wane
allegations of drug use and sexual abuse
accusations against diaz they found to
start at the surface in 97 the rights in
the name manure were sold the remaining
members continued to perform as mdo
until despairment however this iteration
has continued to perform sporadically
new management of a noodle started in
2007
uh golden era blah blah blah blah blah i
don't know
wait
who's diaz 250 that he was the guy who
founded it
215 to present click on that 2015 to
present
when did ricky martin come in i don't
know
all right a lot of
all right got some tragic tragedy
surrounding that one of the guys tried
to kill himself let's get back to coke
pepsi
well uh
i mean i don't know what there is really
well
let's just start the battle i guess yeah
let's just get it do it ready yes are we
gonna do a
we should chat tired i'm tired too
that's where we should change okay
oh god
are you ready yeah salty
whatever you want alright ready yeah
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty
stop
thinking
period
great yeah i just it's just too much
okay it's just too much i agree i'm
tired of discussing i'm tired of going
over everything
i agree yes please okay edit give it a
rest okay nobody cares i agree
i agree sound advice
okay
and figure it out all right let's start
the battle
time for
i'm not going to deny that i know it i'm
here all right coca-cola is like
budweiser coca-cola is like apple pie
coca-cola is
christmas it's clydesdale it's americana
polar bear i get it it's the yankees
it's it's it's
it's the thing it's it's iconic it is
pop culture it is it's beyond the soda
it's defined generations it's the only
it's the only soda it's the only
beverage
like branded beverage i mean it is the
only branded beverage outside of maybe
jack daniels that makes its way into
decorations
like coke is the only decorative
beverage you'd never see a sprite sign
on the wall in somebody's apartment you
know what i mean you never see a nobody
has a cup in their cupboard that says
sprite on it coca-cola has made its way
into decor it's wild it's wild i
understand i understand and i cannot
deny any of that all i'm saying is two
things ready for the
entirety i i don't know which came out
first they might have been close to each
other we'll find all this out uh we'll
do pepsi and coke
uh
but what were you gonna say for the
entirety of what uh for the entirety of
coke's run pepsi is is right on it's
number two right doing the same kind of
thing pepsi is also iconic and it's it's
logo it is you know it's it's it's it's
it was they ruined it it's like coke
whoa what wait coke was made in we went
over this because i remember i found out
coca-cola coca-cola had cocaine in it
yeah so that's a strike against
coca-cola in my book strike eight may
eight
coca-cola
was sold the first class of coca-cola at
jacob's pharmacy in downtown atlanta may
8 1886.
wow that's actually i'm not
excuse me i'm not that surprised by that
year on that that doesn't
that's not if it had said it was older
than that i would have hold on this is
very interesting right
not that much later in relative to now
but 30 years later in 1890 no it was
1886 sorry 13 years later a chemist
named khalid calibratum created pepsi
cola a carbonated cauldron crafted to
refresh and energized customers
of his newborn north carolina drug store
so go back one second so they both
originated in pharmacies that's not
surprising
you know this [ __ ] will eat the paint
off your car i mean you know what i mean
like no but that's really that's really
interesting it's not even like it's not
even like it was made like as a company
or started in a factory they were both
made by people
at pharmacies that's that's a kind of a
crazy step i i hear you it's interesting
i'm not as surprised by it though as as
you are because
i i guess in my head i'm like who else
would have invented a drink like this
you know what i mean so here's here's
the argument but wait but wait before we
get too far from it pimp see if pepsi
also had cocaine in it at one point
because it said the design of pepsi was
to energize
yeah which is what the design of coke
was
it says uh probably not right
wow let me read this before such things
became illegal many products had what we
now consider illegal and dangerous
substances pepsi did not have now legal
additives but 7up had lithium in it
back then and ginger ale originally had
carbolic acid but before it was illegal
coca from cocoa plant leaves was found
in many products from butter to wine to
topical medications to children's
cough medicines if you've ever heard the
term
loudonum
in old western films of books that was a
common cural that was basically
distilled alcohol and opium it was used
by both adults and children and very
often abused all right so it's not as
it's not as notorious
that's the wrong term uh um uh
it's not as
uh
notorious
it's not as scandalous as we thought it
was they made it sound like they were
dumping
meatballs in the coaster
drinking it it was it was the it's the
the base of cocaine the cocoa leaf
whatever was used in many products
coca-cola being one of those that's a
very very different scenario it's easy
to understand where coca cola comes from
where does the name pepsi come from
pepcid maybe or pepsin
like a pepsi was first introduced as
brad's drink in north carolina in 1893
the other one said 1898.
so we're seven years apart it was
advertised to relieve
dyspepsia indigestion ah wow
that's where the name comes from wow so
the name pepsi
literally comes from the root word
dyspepsia so the name itself means
indigestion
that's interesting that's interesting
now let me tell you something
you mentioned the logos of pepsi being
iconic
this is and this is my biggest strike
against pepsi aside from that it tastes
worse and isn't good and
nobody's ever excited when they say
you have pepsi in a restaurant instead
of coke nobody ever likes that nobody is
ever happy about that but
my biggest gripe with pepsi is
pepsi
coca-cola has a warmth to it
it's in the logo it's in the vibe the
whole the whole thing pepsi had that at
one point
and then they changed the brand the logo
they changed the way they advertised it
pepsi to me now looks
if if i ever had
if i ever had to pick a drink off the
shelf
that literally looked like chemicals
it's pepsi pepsi looks so industrial
and sterile there's nothing warm about
it the revised logo so we're talking
about your current logos here right so i
i'm not really going to focus i agree
that pep uh coke is the iconic logo
right but pepsi i like the old logo when
we were growing up like that i'm saying
that it was white and blue and i'm
saying they ruined it i thought it was
awesome so but here's what i'm going to
lean on first this is just some fun
stats but i'm going to tell you where my
argument's going to come from pepsi cola
became the first company introduced
motorized vehicle delivery for soda
based drinks in 1908. uh in 1972 pepsi
became the first u.s product to be
marketed and sold in the former soviet
union uh the president of okay pepsi was
the first company to introduce two-liter
bottles to the market so i mean look
pepsi is doing its thing most soft
drinks probably known uh pepsi for its
soda but pepsi is not just a soda
company pepsico holds a host of other
products that are
few are familiar with the modern pepsico
company is a product of the merger
between pepsi cola and frito-lay there
was a likelihood of one giant soda brand
and no competition between pepsi and
coca-cola on three occasions between 22
and 33 pepsi offered coca-cola the
opportunity to acquire it coca-cola
turned down all three invitations
pepsi became the first brand to
advertise via skywriting mode at the
world's fair pepsi was the first company
to hire black sales executives pepsi
products are consumed more than 200
countries
uh pepsi is the largest food and
beverage company in north america i
can't believe it's not as big as
coca-cola i want to well i want to speak
to that
pepsi
pepsi owns so much [ __ ]
and because they own so much [ __ ] so
much [ __ ] that i love
takes a hit
i hate that when i go to taco bell i
have to get pepsi i hate when i go to
kfc i have to get pepsi like these
they're
regal movie theater which i'm a i'm a
monthly you know i have the the regal
pass or whatever they only have pepsi i
hate that pepsi puts their [ __ ] into so
much stuff but it's because they own so
much stuff
pepsi man is an awesome video game by
the way you're kidding me you know the
video game so okay apparently
playstation one game it's it's a great
game okay i'm serious pepsi apparently
in the 1990s in japan
pepsi had
a
what would you call this a uh
a mascot a [ __ ] an
eponymous japanese superhero mascot
called pepsi his name was pepsi man
focuses on players avoiding there was a
video game developer playstation
what not only did i not know there was
not only did i not know there was a a
mascot never there's a video game of him
it's a great game so he looks like he
looks like a cross between like iron man
and spider-man or something
he's in a sort of faceless it's not even
like a cute like marker it's like a he
looks like a superhero he looks like a
can comes to life that's basically what
can we see any other photos of him he
looks like sort of like one of the blue
cans from the 90s came to life that was
what the outfit was based on clearly but
he's ripped and shreddy look he he he
looks like venom
yeah like in a blue without a face
though there's it's a faceless thing
because it's supposed to be the can
but the plot of the game is
uh people are out of pepsi you've got to
get pepsi to them no way
it's a runner oh my god so you're you're
you're you're a guy oh my god it's like
grand theft auto well sort of yeah but
before grand theft auto he's running the
streets i'm trying to tell you what it
is is he free roaming oh boy
i'm asking you baby i'm free roaming no
i'm listening to me
it's a runner so you're running you your
guy is running forward period you can't
stop that from happening
all you can do is slow down move left to
right
dodge jump whatever and the whole thing
is you're you're being set on this
course you're going to be non-stop and
obstacles are coming up and you've got
to collect as many cans as possible
without dying the way you die is every
time you get hit you lose cans if you
run out of cans you that it's game over
and you see it's just it's kind of like
paperboy remember paperboy where you're
moving forward no matter what i love
that he's running through people's
houses it's like first bueller it's
super fun man it's a really really fun
game it looks fun and i i mean i've
never heard of pepsi man that's crazy
yeah um so i guess you got this game in
the 90s because
i think you go like you got it like for
free with like
a subscription or something game makes
no sense you he he's he's he's a man
he's a superhero made of pepsi running
down the street in regular neighborhoods
and through people's literal houses he
goes in the front door and through their
living room and kitchen and runs out the
back door and he's just swiping cans of
pepsi that are in the street it makes no
sense now there's a scene of him running
from a massive pepsi can that's headed
toward him like a boulder in indiana
jones it's so fun
for the listeners on the don't realize
salsa has for many years been a
proponent of a more grounded pepsi video
game
but it just doesn't make logical sense
what the hell do you want the pepsi
video game to be i don't know the
goddamn video game about pepsi
it's amazing so here's what i'm going to
lean on for my argument okay
and i'm curious because
i'm curious because you've already
admitted fully that
coke is clearly the winner
what could your argument be other than
pepsi is the best ever being second
place wrong here's where i'm gonna go
with you okay and we should read
coca-cola [ __ ] too but
hello
fresh
hey you fresh hello fresh how you doing
fresh hello good to see you fresh
uh i love hello fresh
why because you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
you got a pack schedule this fall
i do
with what you might ask none of your
damn business
but i got stuff going on and hellofresh
has me covered with a weekly selection
of 30 plus recipes and 70 plus
convenience items
all of them delivered right to my door
they could be doing the same for you
what are you waiting for enjoy the
freshest fl fall flavors
fall flavors not flaw favors
fall flavors you got me
every hellofresh recipe includes ripe
just pick produce that travels from the
farm right to your door all right you
can get the whole family involved and by
the way hello fresh
they got
limited edition kid-friendly baking kits
what's more fall than bacon with the
kids
it's time for the bacon it's time for
the fall it's time for hello fresh let's
go people i'm telling you it's great
this is such a cool thing uh what i love
about it is i like to cook i like to
make my own food but you don't always
have time uh meaning you don't always
have time to go to the store you don't
always have time to make the stuff
because elaborate meals could take more
time and
hello fresh takes care of all of it
they're delivering the stuff to your
door no store
these are quick meals to make
and
that saves you time i mean it's it's
obvious people you you get what this is
all right it's it makes perfect sense
trust me do it go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds tastebud65 and use the code
tastebuds 65 for 65 off plus free
shipping again hellofresh.com
tastebuds 65 and use the code tastebud65
for 65 off plus free shipping
hellofresh hellofresh america's number
one meal kit
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
guys it can be tough to train your brain
to stay in problem-solving mode when
faced with a challenge in life that's
all i do i feel like i'm a professional
problem solver before i was a uh the job
i have now which is you know writing
jokes writing television and
problem solving for my entire cast and
show and all that stuff i used to be a
bartender and owned a business and it
was the same thing and it just
you could tell by my tone and look at my
face that it's just too much
but when you learn how to find your own
solutions there's no feeling better a
therapist can help you become a better
problem solver make it easier for you to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small and that is where a better help
comes into play i tell you right now i
go to therapy i encourage therapy i try
to get family and friends at therapy so
if you've never tried it you always
wondered about it this is a real easy
way to start without having to go
somewhere and meet someone in person um
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try try better help it's great options
convenient it's accessible it's
affordable it's entirely online um get
matched with a therapist to filling out
a brief survey and you can switch
therapists any time and you don't even
have to be seen on the camera but you
can speak to someone and that's where it
all starts so
when you want to become a better problem
solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
tastebuds today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
buds
here's where i'm gonna go with you
coca-cola
most iconic brands
in the zeitgeist responsible for art and
pop culture and some christmas things
name coca-cola came off
we should check sales i'm sure coca-cola
sells more but here you go take all of
it take all of that
i honestly and truly believe
and this is the crux of this podcast and
why we do it i believe pepsi tastes
better you're out of your mind i don't
shall shut up i think coca-cola's
i think coca-cola
is okay but i think pepsi tastes better
i don't know what's in pepsi that
has it something that's giving you
cancer from coke
something something's in pepsi something
is in pepsi like pepsi tastes different
from each of them but there's this taste
that pepsi has
that i
we should look at the ingredients in
both and maybe there's an article about
what the main ingredient is that has
them tasting different but
i honestly truly bottom line think pepsi
tastes better
i really do and and i don't have pepsi
as often because it's not available as
often when you go out to eat and i don't
really drink soda but like in out
throughout my life pepsi is harder to
come by in the water
you're telling me
you have the audacity i wanted to read
whatever that that salesman audacity to
sit here and tell me that you sit down
at a restaurant and go could i have a
pepsi that's that's what comes out of
your mouth first and then they go sorry
we only have coke and you go uh
uh you're the opposite of everybody in
the world that sits down and says al the
coke and they go sorry we only have
pepsi so coke i think became also uh all
right there's a lot of things going on
here we keep okay
let me let me address this and we'll go
to that um
coke i think what's the what's the name
of the phrase that's like when the
product becomes so
no no it's like you say i'll give me a
kleenex when you even mean any tissue
you say i want to xerox this when you
mean you want to make a copy but xerox
is the brand
it's not synonymous coke became
synonymous with cola
the name coke became synonymous with
cola
what does it say
well that's this is when a word becomes
no just put what just put what is is
xerox there it is so wait let's and
that's saying let's say you're using the
term as a verb no
yeah but that's what it is well it's not
well i i'm making a parallel in that i
think a lot of people are coming in or
whatever i i i'm happy no it's not a
homonym
xerox popsicle turned house yeah but
what is that called
or i'm sorry a synonym excuse me not
hominin
a generousization i don't know that's
not the worst
synonym synonymous synonymous what's
harmony again click on click on
that article right opposite
xerox popsicle and dirty
what does it say right there
it becomes a generic all right well
whatever it is all right wait wait
what's hominin
uh it's not when they sound the same
like oh antony's opposite opposites no
homonym i think is when they sound the
same no
i don't know that's right yeah like it's
like uh
it's
the point is is coke is synonymous with
cola that's the point this is the point
i'm making bro
the point i'm making is just that i
think that people say i'll have a coke
when they sit down what they mean is
they'll have a cola but coke is so
popular it becomes ubiquitous and they
say i have a coke i don't necessarily
think hey everybody who let me know i
don't necessarily think that everybody
who sits down says ah the coke means i
will only accept coke then why the hell
do they say we only have pepsi because
of that exact reason because pepsi is a
brand that is putting their money
in things and then when people say i'll
have a coke and people first of all for
the people that want a coke and get a
pepsi there's that okay i get it so they
say we have pepsi but i also think it
was because
pepsi is like like
nobody on pepsi knows that coke has
become synonymous with cola and i bet
you pepsi
planet earth
i won't just finish my go ahead go ahead
it's a 10 minute point i get it it's
cause i can't make it go ahead good
go ahead
i don't think everybody says i'll have a
coke like you you just blame me you said
you sit down and say i'll have a pepsi i
don't necessarily do that but when i
when i'm like uh i'll take a which i
rarely do now but if i'm like i've a
diet coke and they go we have pepsi i'm
like great i love it i just don't think
to say i'll have a pepsi because more
than likely i'm gonna have the
conversation well we have coke and i'll
be like that's fine too so i'm just like
bring me whatever but i do believe that
pepsi tastes better i really do and i
believe in a blind taste test wait a
second no no stop when we were little i
have a response to the point this is
where i cut you off pepsi because you're
going to go into five different points
all right go ahead let me go into the
the initial point that you overexplained
okay okay i understand what you're
saying nobody on planet earth ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever
has been disappointed when they had to
drink coke over pepsi
everybody on planet earth has been
disappointed when they have to drink
pepsi over coke that's a dumb dumb
statement it's not a dumb statement it
is you're speaking in absolutes both
both ways in absolutes it's ridiculous
because absolutes exist no you you do
yourself a disservice when you speak in
absolutes and you give ever ever ever
ever always always always always you
discredit yourself right okay because
that didn't happen what you just said as
a matter of fact the opposite happened
right people have been disappointed and
not both ways back and forth right wait
wait are you telling me
that i'm using colorful language is that
what you're doing no i'm telling you i
guess you're being hyperbolic i am
i know but it's it's still stupid
because you're trying to prove a point
stupid if we were on in a debate like a
debate club right now on stage debating
and you said that it wouldn't be the
audience you'd be ripped to shreds gonna
be ripped to shreds because it's not a
sound argument
okay logical i'll i'll i'll say it in
literal terms then
most people
meaning the majority
are only disappointed when pepsi is
offered as the substitution for coke
and the opposite of that is also true
let me speak to that
that is
specifically
your opinion based on nothing the polls
will tell us
the polls won't tell us what you just
said the polls will tell us what people
prefer that that's what i'm saying
now but you're saying that they'll be
disappointed if someone says we have
pepsi they prefer one thing over the
other not that they're disappointed
they'll be like fine how many okay
let me phrase it let me phrase it like
this how many times have you been at a
table you ding bad where someone goes
i'll have a coke and they go we only
have pepsi and they go outrageous i'm
leaving somebody else
you only have pepsi milk somebody had a
stand-up joke about this
somebody had a stand-up joker about that
very thing about how absurd that would
be does anybody flip the table over and
when i forget who it was
uh because of course nobody freaks out
if you want to soda that badly you're
gonna drink a soda but i have in fact
at a time when i wanted a coke and they
say we only have pepsi said no thank you
no you haven't you're a liar no you
haven't you're a liar
you're an absolute liar i won't accept
it i won't accept it
he's a liar what does he serve at his
restaurant
what what do you serve at your
restaurant
what do you think we serve
take a wild guess
take a wild guess shasta not only do we
serve coke
i requested that we have coke zero on
the tap because coke zero is the king of
diet sodas
coke
it makes a lot of sense that you a
simile is something yourself with
something that has the word zero in the
title oh oh
look at the big man on the couch since
2004. since 2004 coca-cola has been the
market leader according to industry
statistics pepsi ranks second followed
by dr pepper and snapple in 22 quarter
one pepsi had a market cap of
229 billion while coke had a market cap
of 268 billion
it's not that far apart you're trying to
your drink is the your drink is the
epitome
of the seinfeld
olympics joke it's the epitome the
second yeah yeah yeah of all the losers
you were the first like it is you it is
the epitome of that i don't see
229 billion dollars in sales per quarter
being a failure okay it matters
someone has to be first here's why it's
a
ever because failure is
268 billion so that's why you're that's
great so everything everything that's
first in sales is better than the second
thing no
not at all
not as i just said it's the epitome of
the seinfeld joke out of all the losers
you were the best
in sales maybe but that's what it means
that does not mean that pepsi is not as
good as coke so a couple days you could
take your santa clauses you could take
your clydesdales and you could take your
polar bears i got michael jackson
i got michael jackson the pedophile
the pedophile prove it this is who
you're bringing to the table
prove it this is your breathing table
prove it no i can't talk because coke's
got cosby
yeah
department proving that i'm doing great
cosby's improving
flavor ask any soda drinker the biggest
difference between coke and pepsi and
nine times out of ten the answer will be
that pepsi is sweeter that's not
surprising considering pepsi has two
more grams of sugar than you know what's
worse for 12 months so it's worse
give me a calorie count pip give me a
calorie count pimp i'm sure they're the
same calories not with two grams more
sugar
all right one calorie count is one 150
it's the same vanilla coke's 150. we're
not talking about coke we're talking
regular coke
150
139 suck it
suck it volcano that's sucking coke is
not 139. that's a lie you i i
why would it said my favorites are right
there 140 one 40. and i just said it's
not 139. nine years
[ __ ] that's not what i was arguing i
was arguing it wasn't one thirty nine
i've never met you you would never you
were you would never pieces calories one
calorie really you don't be [ __ ] right
my point is that it's not 139 it sounded
ridiculous
that's not a rounded number that's no i
said it's probably 150. then it said 139
i said that's not why okay
139. let me ask you a question why is
the 140 true in the second part of the
google page and the 139 is false because
you choose to believe the one over there
no you dope turn a can sideways it'll
never say 139 okay ever okay that's all
i was saying 139 is insane it would not
say 139 they round up or they make sure
it's round you think you're going to
turn a cocaine outside because they 139
no no
no i didn't say that i didn't say that
i didn't say that
i didn't say that
i want to can you put in a blind tape
coca-cola blind taste test please google
it
please you're afraid pepsi challenge you
idiot yeah you idiot
the only time people like pepsi better
is in the commercials for pepsi when
they do the fake
the pepsi challenge is everything you
need to know pepsi challenge is a mic
drop pepsi won the battle but lost the
challenge pepsi challenge
you can gain a lot of insights when you
look at the ideas and tactics that
created legendary marketing today we're
breaking down the pepsi challenge the
pepsi challenge signaled a major shift
in the winds of the cola landscape in
1975 coke was 800 the 800-pound gorilla
in the cola market holding number one
position for decades a superior
distribution system an effective
marketing and incredible brand loyalty
created the legions of happy customers
pepsi was the new kid on the block
looking to prove something they were
hungry and willing to mix it up a savvy
exec at pepsi came up with a bold
revolutionary strategy to do just that
the idea was the pepsi challenge pepsi
went inside malls and around the country
and invited people to do a blind t-test
between coke and pepsi the results were
remarkable
over coke by a significant margin pepsi
happily recorded results in a tv
campaign much of their own surprise by
the way according to got jumpy and felt
compelled to respond they started
issuing press releases
and they responded saying that coke was
better they came across a defensive and
they came across as paranoid their pr
campaign and denials were a disaster
pepsi had momentum
peddling sharing a market share free
falling
you can't read the whole article since
everyone actually liked pepsi better
after all that's what the results proved
let's be more like them and change the
secret formula to copy
paper and
guess what beat them guess what join
them and guess what and tap that
immediately when everybody said this
sucks and tap that immediately when
everybody says this sucks you're gonna
throw you're gonna put gabe kaplan in my
face poked answer with me newcastle
don't speak
welcome back connor do not speak bad of
him he was an icon in the late 70s
you were scared you were running scared
you do introduce new coke you know what
to do yourself everybody's like new coke
get that you had no i'm gonna get your
product you understand something you
have nothing to do
listen to what i'm about to see scared
bro
shut up yeah that's what i'm gonna say
to you listen to you welcome back connor
was a popular sitcom your spokesperson
was gabe cotter ours was john travolta
oz was michael jackson folks prize picks
is a new app and website that are
sponsoring the podcast that's a lot of
fun uh if you love sports um price pixel
offers projections on any sport that you
watch includes nfl nba
mlb nhl pga college football college
basketball women's college basketball
soccer wnba
nascar tennis boxing disc golf i mean it
goes cricket even
um how does it work well i've played it
i've won a bunch of cash already i
basically do football so i would say
like tonight i i um i'm picking patrick
mahomes to have 300 over 300 yards or
cooper cup to have at least a touchdown
and that's how it works you basically
pick two to five players and if they
score more or less than the prize uh
picks projections you can win up to 10
times your money on the entry it's not
competing against other people it's just
you versus the projections that are
available entries can be made in 60
seconds or less it's that easy safe and
fast withdrawals as well and it's
currently operational in over 30 states
and canada it's really fun especially
now that nfl is starting this week
check it out download the prize picks
app or go to prizepix.com to sign up and
play daily fantasy sports i've been
playing fantasy sports right now for i
just figured this out for 24 years
it's fun it's just it makes it makes the
enjoyment it makes me the sports more
fun for me first time users can receive
a 100 instant deposit match up to 100
with the promo code taste buds if you
deposit 100 bucks price picks gives you
100 bucks if you deposit 50 prices will
give you 50. just go in don't forget to
enter the promo code tastebuds that sign
up for an instant deposit match up to
100 price picks check it out
guys let's talk about noom noom right
now let me ask you a question
i'm in this position right now i'm
trying to lose weight i do things i try
things they don't work i'm try i try to
intermittent fasting that's just i
wonder if that's the way that i really
need to go
uh you know i cut out carbs but then
they come right back i've seen people do
ridiculous things like
juice cleanses for 30 days it just
doesn't seem like the right thing to do
uh noom that is their basically their
mantra their psychology based approach
empowers you with knowledge so you
actually build lasting results it's it's
a more sustainable approach it's not a
crash diet it's just understanding and
changing your relationship with food you
understand um
like encouraging mindful eating or
building a connection with food between
your mind and body if it sounds
a little bit different it is and you
should check it out because it's really
interesting and it's really effective
everybody has a different goal you know
we should we you know
they're suitable to you specifically um
you'll use this thing and you will it's
not just about a weight loss thing too
uh joe uses this uh specifically and
it's
it actually has an emotional mental
thing to it you they they drive you to
feel better spiritually and so they
package all these things together so
there's a mind-body connection with you
and food it's really interesting it's
different it's not a fad diet it's not a
crash to none of those things at all um
and like i said we can't all do the same
regimen everyone's different that's what
they say so you get personalized
programs that empower you specifically
to build your own sustainable habits
um
and there's different levels of support
so you could do like a five-minute daily
check-in to actually getting personal
coaching which is really cool
active numerous lose an average of 15
pounds in 16 weeks and 95 percent of the
customers say noon weight is a good
long-term solution
so if you're done trying everything to
lose weight then try nume wait and i'm
saying noom n-o-o-m sign up for your
trial today at noom.com
tastebud that's n-o-o-m.com
bud to sign up for your trial today
john travolta pulling up pimp john
travolta commercial who's more famous
michael jackson or john travolta no
that's not what i'm saying stupid i'm
saying the time you said you said mine
was gabe kaplan you know what john's
holder what's your point because i'll
i'll checkmate you with michael jackson
shimon
i was i was lying there was judge rule
that wasn't a spokesman you're a [ __ ]
idiot because you'll say anything will
say anything
will
anything to win an argument and you'll
lie lies come out of your mouth i would
love look at this faction reeves keanu
reeves in 1983.
this is like look who was on a whoo look
who was
he was unknown do you think michael
jackson was unknown
brother
you want to talk icon
you you
nobody was bigger than cosby michael
jackson was oh [ __ ] off
i want to do a poll who's bigger michael
jackson cosby and
lose 100
no just in popularity 100 to zero you
want to lose you think bill cosby's
bigger than michael jackson by the way
telling me to [ __ ] off and you set your
guy's hair on fire so congratulations it
is what it is
and i bet you i bet you would have set
his hair on fire was pepsi it's probably
i wonder how many [ __ ] guests i
wonder how many capsules cosby dropped
into a coca-cola that's not what we're
talking about how many kids did michael
jackson lauren with a pepsi in his
dinner bell yeah on his [ __ ] dinner i
saw the doctor's battery pepsi
coke is it
coke is it is your slogan pepsi is the
choice of a new generation
if you shut up if you were that
confident if you were that confident in
your product when pepsi hit the market
and started creaming them they changed
they got scared they didn't they weren't
covered immediately changed it back but
what does it tell you the word classic
to it yeah and nobody batted an eye
everybody was like we accept
because they were scared because pepsi
was better they pulled a job what is
your response and for a second they
brought in the dimwit from alaska and
then they realized they [ __ ] up and
they dropped her oh get that [ __ ] up
talk with sarah palin and that's what
the [ __ ] happened to the pacific
challenge
of the pepsi challenge new coke wasn't
sarah palin you dope
what are you gonna do next the only
thing you could do next is companion who
coke to a
nugget
new coke you
oh i want to hear you i want to hear you
i want to hear you all the major fast
food places aside from the
entrepreneurial ones i mentioned like
taco bell kfc
ancillary taco bell kfc pizza and celery
try to find a pizza at this in this day
and age okay it's like you're getting
you have a better chance finding a
leprechaun taco bell and kfc are
ancillary that makes sense
mcdonald's
burger king
wendy's the trifecta the three biggies
coca-cola baby joe look at me coca-cola
i want you i want you
i want you
i want you to respond i want you to
respond to the pepsi challenge right now
what i just
read open and close i said that i'm
hinging according to juicebox.com no no
no that was your reference song oh by
the way
pick any website you dope anything the
pepsi challenge existed those are all
factual pips okay i want you to pull up
another pepsi challenge article from and
i would have said at the beginning of
this podcast i said fine you want to be
the leader in sales you want to be more
iconic you can under the market first
great this the spirit of this podcast is
based on taste and i'm gonna hinge my
argument on the fact that pepsi tastes
better they did a national survey that
was so lopsided that coke changed their
formula because they were scared that
they didn't taste as good as pepsi which
tastes better pepsi
yeah
couldn't be there speak to it couldn't
just be a marketing champion there's no
way pepsi could have lied about this
yeah oh so much
let's go let's go to let's go to
congress and find the hard numbers of
the pepsi challenge what
about in a country where presidential
elections can be stolen he's gonna
believe that the pepsi challenge is real
you're gonna believe that there's hard
just because you get loud doesn't mean
you're going to win an argument just
because you get loud doesn't mean that
you're going to discredit the pepsi
challenge the pepsi challenge is well
documented you sound like a man listen
we tried we tried to get coke and pepsi
to taste on this one for the first time
ever and we couldn't get it and we
should have it because i swear to christ
i could tell which is pepsi and it
tastes goddamn better so
what numbers are the pips you listen to
yourself right you want to get into it
you want to get into it well google pets
a challenge and i'll [ __ ] sit here
and i'll read the first ten articles no
do not read anymore so what more do you
need to know coca-cola's response was to
change their formula because they
realized how much they were being
outvoted it's set by a significant
margin in your head and in your head you
don't think oh my god we didn't even get
into mixed drinks
rum and coke the lemmy the jack and coke
that's the most iconic that is because
that is because what i said before
people want a jack and a cola they don't
care about the coke that's not true this
is yes i mixed pepsi with liquor it's
gross i'm sure you have that's right i'm
sure you have
oh what's that supposed to be i'm sure
you've mixed everything with liquor
i'm sure you've mixed everything
i'm sure you've mixed everything i'm
sure you've missed
fanta yeah okay i'm sure
yeah and you know why you think pepsi is
good because you're a goddamn pothead
burnout who's high all the time who
thinks anything tastes good because
you're [ __ ] higher than i'd rather be
a pothead than a cokehead oh my god you
just said i i love it i love that it has
coke in it you just said that i i made
the joke that it was just that it was a
shot you're making sure so you're you're
sliding with coke
strikes
the uh but i mean anybody's [ __ ] all
tooted up anything tastes good yeah yeah
yeah i know
i know i know
[ __ ] you you'll mix uh you'll mix uh uh
uh absent with fonta that's what you
would do no i wouldn't yes you you're
just like what are those two things and
i put them together it wouldn't that's
my point when you mix when i was in
college and you didn't go to college
when i was in college we would buy pepsi
sometimes to make uh uh whiskey cokes
with pepsi
because the pepsi
because the pepsi was cheaper it would
always be on sale for like
i hate you i hate you sometimes i really
hate you so now you now you see he
caught himself saying that he actually
used to do pepsi
his is that there was a probably a five
cent difference in the chaos i'm telling
you something yeah we would buy the two
liters of pepsi because they were 75
cents outside of the two liter okay
great doesn't matter my point is it
never tasted right and we would always
make the joke that we could only afford
the cheaper version of one that we
wanted to drink that wasn't as good let
me ask you a question because it didn't
taste good let me question hinge you're
hinging your argument on that let me ask
you a question what was the price
difference between the can of coca-cola
oh the two-liter cocoa and two-liter of
uh pepsi because when i was growing up
the two leaders were about 79 to 99
cents when i was
what could you afford could you not
afford the dine
splurge on the coca-cola college when i
was in college yeah the supermarket near
where we live
always had this 75 cent sale on the two
liters of pepsi okay and how much was
the cocoa [ __ ] broke i was pulling
change out of my couch to drink i had no
[ __ ] money okay i literally told me
that you couldn't afford the 10
difference to bump up to the drink you
like i'm telling you what broke college
kids did because it was a deal that's
what i'm telling you and it never tasted
as good all right and when you're in
college
on a two liter is it 75 extra cents bro
it was probably 10 cents whatever that's
what we did because we were broken i
believe that i believe that okay i
believe that you did yeah i believe that
you believe
pepsi every time when you just said you
turned pepsi away at restaurants you
chose it every time you drank to save a
dime uh your honor your honor in support
of my case i'd like to cite the pepsi
challenge
also other data i'd like to call up
batman versus superman
um
can i say something uh in a court of law
in a court of law in a court of law
i'd like to refer to the bit wars snes
versus sega genesis
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
goddamn [ __ ] nimrod keep keep adding
keep adding unfunny tags until somebody
laughs that was good that was really
funny
really funny nobody even knew the last
[ __ ] four references you made
you sit in your house you read [ __ ]
comics that no one ever heard about you
[ __ ] jack off to him nobody knows
nobody knows sega genesis versus super
nintendo whatever the hell you said
before that anyway the point is they
were all unfunny right miser from the
from the christmas oh heat myself yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's actually that's
good
how many tags were you going to do until
you got to mcdonald's how many songs are
you going to sing okay let me ask you a
question
let me ask you a question yeah in a
court of law or in a debate
wouldn't the number one thing to bring
up between what tastes better
a taste test
it depends if you want to operate
scientifically or out of faith
but he's saying in a court of law your
honor i i present you to pepsi
challenge where are the numbers of the
pepsi challenge i'm saying where are the
stuff okay so you can't trust you think
it's a home
you're going to trust the statistics of
the pepsi yes i am they did it i did it
they did it buddy they did it you sound
just like coca-cola did back then you're
scared it's a marketing campaign okay
what better way what better argument to
bring up in this argument than a blind
taste test that pepsi dominated that's
not appropriate for me to bring up right
now are you kidding me right here
that's a great on the phones pepsi is
where the south succeeded from the union
it's not funny but it makes no sense now
look pepsi
i'm going to say something to support
you
relax yeah
given the comments you might have a
bigger [ __ ] shot at this than we
thought i'm seeing a lot of pro pepsi
talk
love a good fountain pepsi coke is
classic but i find pepsi sweeter than a
can of coke uh the fact that you think a
simple poll like this could answer this
very nuanced question shows that you are
waiting in the territory you have no
business
all right our winners either let's let's
let's let's read these all right he's
far superior scroll i want i want to get
i want to get some phones but both of
those are very funny both of those are
very very clear answer nobody
oh i don't even know
joe please don't take pepsi i didn't
cola is my favorite choice of flavor oh
he's here
he texted me 11 minutes ago he's at the
door
uh cola is my favorite choice of flavor
but but coke and its products are just
slightly better than pepsi oh is it my
favorite choice but they're saying the
overall products are better pepsi didn't
have death squads in columbia
what is that what does that mean i don't
know but it's funny doesn't matter a
blind test taste test it's hard to tell
them apart pepsi is born in the
carolinas
scroll pimpy
uh if i'm drinking soda i want to feel
like it's punching me in the throat coke
all day
pepsi is too smooth which is nice the
bottle of pepsi is flat before it hits
your tongue
you'll stop it and be real i i'd rather
[ __ ] in my hands and clap to drink pepsi
[Laughter]
well we got some really funny ones today
uh
i'm convinced people who vote for coke
are either a have never had a pepsi or b
are too scared to speak the truth jimmy
simpson i love you
coco always
coke always leaves a weird film on my
teeth wait what what is why did you just
say jimmy simpson i love you because oh
his
i thought it was the actor jimmy the guy
from the guy from westworld his name's
jimmy simpson he's a good actor
yeah be in your own world it's fine i
thought you knew jimmy simpson for a
second
i thought it was cool
why is that not okay
say what you will about pepsi but i like
to see back to the future try to be as
cool as as it as it was without it oh my
god pepsi free
pepsi free yeah of course one of the
best trilogies lemon tree actually this
could be our winner [ __ ] pepsi i think
could be the winner
all right let's wrap it up we got to go
to the vote who's our winning uh
who's our winning compliment uh hold on
hold on i don't know what you're saying
let's go to the let's go to humblefy
well no but we got to retweet the the
best comment
the one
the [ __ ] in my hands and clap yeah
that's funny okay
follow
follow uh jade alex photo alex photo
j-a-d-e alex a-l-e-x photo
all right okay um
guys
merch is available uh and it's going uh
on our websites or the link on the on
the bottom of this video right there's a
link on this video for the merch guys
support the pod buy some merch uh this
way you can show it around and subscribe
to the channel subscribe to the youtube
channel at no press uh
rate us on itunes follow on spotify
follow the clips page by the way we have
we have a clips page just i mean the pod
is free guys so any of that stuff would
really help us if you're a fan that's
okay i think we all know where this is
going okay
that's unbelievable yeah give a retweet
today that's our boy jack
jack martelly sacks we he's he's uh
he's one of the super fans
that is such a funny can you throw it up
on the screen the illusion of free
choice he has a cow standing in between
two hallways once coke wants pepsi but
in the end they meet and it always ends
up just being joe braces
and it happened follow jack uh bertelli
b-e-r-t-e-l-l-i-s-a
that actually is a fun t-shirt that's a
great t-shirt that's a great t-shirt
that's a great t-shirt jack can we use
that as a t-shirt
are you guys ready yeah
as i thought i mean i gotta be honest 31
000 votes it's not the drubbing i
thought it would be i thought this was
gonna be like 85 14. i thought it was
going to be 15. those would be 60 40
60 40. it's 67.9 coca-cola to 32.1
percent pepsi uh pimp you pimp's gonna
throw that up on the screen along with
the
current win losses right yes all right
folks i still love you babe i love you
too
taste buds they come to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools gonna fight
but only one food can be right